hey guys it's Johanna here so most of us
do desire a flat and toned
tummy well is it achievable of course it
is however it is important to know that
to get a flat tummy it is not about
doing hundreds of crunches every single
day instead it is a combination of
regular total body workout which
includes strength and cardio training to
really burn the excess fat off you have
to watch over your diet because what you
eat matters and it will show and of
course combined with regular core regard
to strengthen your core and to tighten
this midsection so beginners I've
designed this 5 minute workout just for
you to start strengthening your core and
also to gain a flatter tummy take it at
your own pace as you progress you can
choose the harder variation increase the
time and increase the repetitions for
best result do this workout 3 times
weekly on alternate days here are the
workouts basic crunches toe tip head to
toe touch Russian twist and plank
each workout will last for 40 seconds
with 20 seconds of rest try to do as
many repetitions
you can without sacrificing the proper
form so let's start with the question
regarding which is basic crunches okay
so like on flats they said he'll push
your pod and as you crunch out in to
leave your shoulders up okay up and
crush so you're lifting assurance off
and relax again AG and just look at one
point to really work on your ass okay if
you feel that in that is hunting that
might be because you're actually trying
to try to reconnect instead of your
shoulders so just crunch up look at one
point and just relax in that few laps
working good keep going
rich keep going nice crunch and slow
down
crunch and control very good so this
workout will be working on and gotta ask
one more and just rest for 20 seconds
the second workout will be toady okay
this workout targets yellow ass so the
two legs up mighty decrease place your
arms by his side and what you want to do
this is to bring your both feet down to
the floor
punch look it up if your tail would off
slightly and just touch her here let's
go back we can turn off and touch good
there you go just small movement you
should really feel when I lower halves
working good up touch and up so control
down touch and up as you progress you
can accept your next fold up and keep
your legs straight
so beginners 90-degrees touch and lift
it up good so really work and target
your little apps touch up good gentle
touch
do not press it feet on the ground and
just touch it and lift it up few more
one and rest third work down head to toe
crunch okay
so both feet level to the floor arms up
as you can chop reach opposite hand and
opposite toes right so you should do the
couch so you're angry at working at the
side as well
ready up couch and tweaks good there you
go
head to toe good up and to toe nice
crunch there you go
don't and AH good so twist slightly to
work on the side of it ass as well
if you come touch that's all right you
don't try to reach as far as you can and
as you keep doing and to keep
progressing you will be able to reach so
again you like so mad and really use
your ass and get your abs to crunch all
the way up up and control good and now
up fourth work up Russian twist to
really work on the side of the ass okay
so just place both feet on to the floor
lean your body back slightly keeps you
keeping both guys together and just
twist side to side okay
simple right just side to side and
really engage the side of the ass and
twist good there you go we've got it
down and you should feel the side of ABS
working just like rowing a boat again as
you progress then in to leave both legs
on the floor - Russian twist take your
own pace
beginneth place both feet onto the pole
and just roam roh-roh
imagine you're going boom good keep
going side to side twist good do more
and rest
final final workout play play it's going
to work on your entire core and to
really work on your lower back as well
okay you know everybody needs a starting
point
some of you can only do 10 seconds of
plank and that's fine
what obvious [ __ ] point is keep going
and right let's go play so up remember
to keep your body in a straight line
okay
tighten your core do not leave it too
high up this is wrong or do not arch
your back
this is wrong so straight line fit
together suck your tummy in and just
type in a core and just hold it at this
position okay breathe in and out you
know just think about something else
besides doing plank as you get stronger
challenge yourself and add extra ten
seconds okay good ten to the core focus
three more seconds and well done guys
well well well done that was five
minutes of a breakout now just reach
forward and stretch it out so that was
five minutes of really simple abs
workout to strengthen and tone to the
midsection
if you are an absolute beginner start
with one set as you progress increase
the two sets and eventually in
three or four steps you can also choose
a harder variation increase the workout
time and decrease the rest time do this
workout do your put the body workout and
eat a well-balanced diet and trust me in
a week's time you will see and feel the
difference on your belly all of us for
new fitness food and motivational videos
please like share and subscribe to my
youtube channel and website do you
follow me on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter to stay connected with me thanks
guys
you
you